I do want to mention one quick thing too  I had a phone call with Google today  they're panicking over section 230  reform uh so the Supreme Court has  agreed to take up a case pertaining to  recommendations and so YouTube is now  actively lobbying prominent creators I  suppose I got an email and it asked me  to sign up for a certain date to talk to  their head of policy it's very nice but  uh I was uh uh personally offended at  the things that he was saying so I'm not  trying to be mean to the guy we're going  to talk again probably tomorrow but uh  it seemed like they were trying to Lobby  me to agree that YouTube should have the  right to be politically biased and be  immune from defamation which I  absolutely do not so we'll talk about  that too but we got to get into this